hey guys here at Wine Library just
filming some wine videos for the store
but real quick before you go into
today's vlog it is time to subscribe to
my channel so many of you not doing it
like for mine
we scroll up for a solid right hook this
is the opportunity please please please
subscribe but sure exactly the UI it
would mean the world to me hope you
enjoy today's vlog
[Music]
I need to run that Thank You Cesar
Scooby dude nice job this is a very
meaningful gift because this is a very
very very you have to be hardcore me fan
you have to know a lot about me to know
this my favorite cartoon is the laugh
Olympics which is a cartoon that like
nobody knows existed first of all it was
a 70s cartoon I only saw it because if
they replayed it on USA and one of the
it's it's groups of cartoons competing
against each other and one of the teams
was called the Scooby doobies and this
is what that is I love this thank you
man I'm gonna definitely rock their hay
blog going to a new partnership meeting
opportunity for pure well and iris is
breaking things and we'll see you later
[Music]
what I think is when I care about
something I think I know how to hack
culture to make something relevant that
people actually start has the
disproportionate ROI in my opinion for
where I feel passionate about it from a
standpoint is actual business and I
think this is the engine and the
framework to create a world where you
know me I'm a disruptor that's practical
I know for a fact that I I just know
that for a fact just had a crazy call
with a client big-time stuff
Pyrus you'll figure out how to beat 98%
of it you some things that meant nothing
but giving you guys the context trying
to close
a multi-million dollar deal we don't
show this part of me but like show from
the beginning timestamp it would be you
know I'll give you guys the preview
actually I'm adding the timestamp it was
a 30 minute call exactly these are the
things I want to show more of I just
spent 30 minutes trying to feel one of
the biggest brands in the world to do a
sponsorship thing in the gallery the
pure whale world it would be million
duck millions of dollars in revenue this
is what I do when you don't see me
[Music]
businesses say sneakers so building
businesses
[Music]
the car velocity
I'm so happy the way it all worked out
what up what a missed opportunity would
have been for both of us to be left yeah
I'm so glad you got came to that
realization you're such a special girl
like you're gonna we're gonna do so well
together can help you so much it's like
the best decision you ever made
really
like
yeah
like seriously
yeah I know listen anybody who picks up
that's like you lived it yeah but then
to be able to come in the inside and
actually see how real it is to know it's
even more real yeah
that's why I passions reach more people
and I know what your I of course I know
why you're excited
[Music]
Blagh iris and I just had a very
important conversation and I'm gonna
force her to share it sorry iris so here
it is we just did it 10 minutes ago or
she just played it and now I'm doing
this part it's funny and I'll continue
which it was what I'm gonna say next
3:56 rolling into Wine Library once a
year I take vaynermedia New York to wine
library's it's closed and people do
their holiday Thanksgiving shopping it's
a fun day it's kind of meshing my two
worlds so 90 or so almost 100 of the
employees are either here now or two
here yet you know oh yeah oh they came
wild oh yeah awesome anyway nonetheless
a bunch of Wine Library people here
right now Manor being vaynermedia people
are here right now at Wine Library here
are some of the highlights here we have
the the the man the myth the legend guys
this is a Sasha Vaynerchuk he's the
owner
founder proprietor CEO chairman of the
board of wine library nice knickers
where yours what do you have to say to
all the young entrepreneurs dad what's a
good piece of advice from you all the
years of wisdom being a successful
entrepreneur truly coming from nothing
and building what's a good piece of
advice good this advice yeah work hard
and just keep investing in what you
believe
what are you 20 back for you know your
fellow workers who works with you
because that's what makes me really
successful but why were you successful I
had nothing to lose
let's start with really I had nothing
for lying
what about tenacity do you think you
just willed it to success
to make bit tonight not as big as you
are nobody's gonna nobody's gonna end up
being able to say that when I'm done
with this sub gang hey hey hey hi hey
how are you guys hi you guys having fun
it's my dad Sasha hi are you horny
pleasure so men are you doing Jason how
are you brother sure hello you doing a
great job rather think so I'm so proud
of you literally for the first person of
my thesis to be working out this well
it's a big deal because if it didn't
work and he quit or he was like suck it
or I was like [ __ ] this like it would be
different it's so important for the
first one to work I'm gonna hire six
more of you like six minutes that's the
plan
seriously I mean look I think you're
special dude and but I think I get six
emails like that a year and I'm gonna
try people that are smart for you to be
this smart to take one step backwards
for 54 steps forward that's just [ __ ]
smart and it's so obvious right it's
obvious to you because that's why you're
doing it but it's obvious to me you know
the Irish quit and then re unclip that's
amazing that's what I should quit and
then she was like but then she was like
mm check eBay let's see what's going on
you gotta see this
now go to complete it and so okay this
is today this is today I mean 200 bucks
you know chew up this is $85 200 once I
got to to buy it now yeah this is just
ridiculous
364 Brannen you made a huge mistake this
is the best eBay arbitrage we've ever
seen and then it's my sneaker and we
type in a get rid of soap so futons this
white older house unreal is this just
like this literally looks like some
upper deck promotion all right give me
something to taste out of my dad's
default face is my favorite thing on
earth
hey wine library email list this is a
Gary Vaynerchuk former host of Wine
Library TV that I used to film in this
office on this table and today's uh mega
offer is the Khan Valley 2015 Chardonnay
Kyle's here what the hell is and left
what the hell are you doing here
that's awesome
all right I love how integrated Boehner
hello grandma grandma Zee hi grandma Zee
how are you ha good happy holidays thank
you we'll figure it out one day have a
great day take care
I mean it's been an incredible ride for
the pedestal that the entrepreneur has
been given in culture in the modern
culture and you know I think what's cool
for me is I really think I'm a real
purebred entrepreneur at it at the
ultimate core like you know there's I've
got the steak and the sizzle and I think
that's what makes a great entrepreneur
and I just think it's really cool I'm so
humbled to be able to represent a thing
and a type of man and woman and I take
that responsibility I'm a new emerging
feeling for me is how good I have to be
because I've been given the opportunity
to you know be an entrepreneur with a
lot of people look at and I think I am
I've got a lot of people are
impressionable when it comes to
entrepreneurship I think there's an
enormous amount of responsibility I have
to do it the right way and so all these
decisions all these marketing concepts
things of the sneaker I take them very
seriously never looking at the
short-term and it's you know this was a
good one I'm very happy about it
I just I have more humility than people
that should have it you know
it's just my gear man look again it's
fun to do this with you because you
worked at and closely too you know
obviously we're in separate offices but
you know you have a very clear feeling
of what I am I'm not fancy man I listen
I think I'm great and all those good
things but I also think I'm [ __ ] and Who
am I to not engage with everybody on
Twitter at 1:30 in the morning if the
website is not working I want to I
respect and I'm humbled by their
attention and admiration and interested
buying something and I'm there to help
and apologize and I'm willing to do
customer service and I'm willing to be
the CEO I'm willing to make 500
million-dollar deals and I'm willing to
you know to carry cases to the to the I
mean I grab a shopping cart today for
somebody like they'll never go I came
from zero man I came from me I came from
not a whole hot man like I was a 14 year
old stock boy you know what I mean like
I had a work-life summers like I've got
work in me like I'm not scared of work
I'm not fancy
there is never graduating there's no
graduating to the next level you release
the sneaker the websites not working you
go on Twitter and [ __ ] answer
people's headaches the end I don't know
if there's anybody getting more out of
what they've got than me and it comes
out of my humility
got it and so you won't get as much as
you've been gifted with charisma and
talent and all that you have because you
think you're special before you are her
brother
take your talk to you that I vlog if
Irish decides Jesus you'll see the
references at a Vasquez former employee
Boehner jump in and doing this thing
before hope he wins what time's our eta
we're going to the garden Google
straighten our yeah
[Music]
[Music]
put a block big day today heading into
mid-november shoe is launched and sold
out
crazy what's going on there
anyway that's done on to the next thing
big day at Vayner just a bunch of
meetings was fun to stop by one library
for an hour good to see my pops sure
that's going to give content
my brother AJ I'll try to get up in here
and this episode with so this is almost
the ending of the episode but good
operations they got a lot done bunch of
the important meetings with a bunch of
big brands a lot of good stuff and and
you know sometimes you know when you're
feeling it like you just know what
you're doing is right
today's one of those days just that
balance of like
stay consent oh Clark Kent and Superman
Gary Vaynerchuk Gary B you know just
living that double cloak like Jekyll and
Hyde kind of things
but it's not like Jekyll and Hyde it's
like which was a good
hobbie who's the good one in Jekyll Hyde
Hyde right the checkles like the checkol
I'm moving that hide and hide life
[Music]
you
you